this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome for another actually you know
the 18th annual lecture about trees I
started back in the mid 90s - when I
realized that every year I learned at
least one cool fact about trees that
ought to be that ought to be known to
more people and and so I started this
series of lectures trees are of course
biologists were supposedly know about
trees and mathematicians and electrical
engineers played around a little bit but
now we we know that it's really the real
intellectual home of trees is computer
science and and I'm happy to celebrate
that also this year is a special year
because it's the centennial of Alan
Turing and and I wanted to make a plug
for something that I an idea that I had
a couple months ago in case you haven't
heard about it there's a there's a
wonderful English word that hasn't been
defined yet and and actually actually
Christmas puppet Mitchell tried to
define it before he knew much English he
only had heard about a Turing machine
and so this is a verb the verb is to
tour and and the and and there's also a
a great need for a verb that we don't
have a word for it
namely to use the Internet and so I'm
proposing that henceforth this verb
means to use the Internet you know so
you know if if you want to if you want
more about it you can you can google it
and look at my news page and everything
like this so anyway this is this is
something that we hope can just spread
like wildfire over the Internet okay now
before the other thing before I get
going I I want to dedicate this lecture
to Pete v-not
who died on Wednesday he was a you know
longtime participant of these lectures
and so I was sad to hear about it of
course but I think I'll try to do run it
right do something that he would have
enjoyed so now title
as you saw it was computer
it was trees and chordal graphs okay so
so this is something that I that I
learned about in July I probably should
have known about it earlier but anyway
it everybody here I'm sure knows what a
graph is but there are two and there are
different classes of graphs you know
some graphs are planar and but some
graphs are bipartite whatever there's
lots of different flavors of graph and
and there's two classes of graphs that
are of particular importance one is
trees or forests these are the the the
graphs that don't have any loops in them
and then there's the chordal graphs are
probably the next most important class
of graphs in applications the reason is
that for for chordal graphs lots of
algorithms that are hard on general
graphs to do we become easy and and so
if you've got if you're faced with a
chordal graph i it's usually you know
you're in luck so and i was playing
around with with graphs in in july i was
the graphs i was looking at i I was
actually trying to calculate something
called the möbius function of a graph
which is which is which is of importance
in statistical physics
you know statistical mechanics of the
physicists and and I I found an
algorithm in the literature that that
worked well on trees and I realized that
I could extend this to luck to more
graphs that that weren't trees and after
okay
and after a couple weeks I realized oh
yeah it's chordal graphs that are the
ones that that are good for the
algorithm that I that I was playing with
in July and so then I started reading up
about chordal graphs I and and and I
found some really nice pretty stuff and
that's not too difficult that I think
everybody ought to know including me and
so I the best way to learn and learn
something is to try to talk a lecture
about it so I'm going to I'm going to
try to tell you about the great story of
chordal graphs so definition what a
chordal great whence the chordal graph
and all this so so now I don't know who
first came up with this definition but
it but there are other names that are
like all good concepts of it they're
discovered by lots of different people
in different in different ways and so
this deep graphs of some people call
them crass but other people call them
rigid circuit graphs they were studying
other kind of application and other
people call them
well triangulated graphs and there's
also minimum filling graph and a bunch
of other names so so it was a while
before that the people who had come up
with these different definitions realize
that they all were talking about the
same concept and the but the most common
name nowadays is chordal graph and
that's because of the following
definition suppose you have a cycle in
the graph I'll just draw a sort of a
random cycle here yeah thanks for
zooming in a little bit okay now
whenever you have a cycle of length
greater than three
then that cycle has to have a cord no
what but I'm looking at vertices in the
graph and and I'm just saying that
there's a cycle which means that there's
a way to get from here to here to here
to here to here to here to here to here
and but I haven't drawn all the edges of
this graph I just said that there's a
cycle now if if the cycle has length
greater than 3 then it's got to have a
cord and the cord is you know a cross
link between 2 and the vertices of the
cycle now why is it called a cord well I
guess it's because you could call this a
cord when he was talking about circles
long ago but anyway it's a and an it and
the word comes back to according the OED
it it you know it it connects to string
it Rick is actually the Greek word means
string and it ended we have vocal cords
and things like that so anyway that's
chordal now take a look at this I I'm
gonna assume that my graph is chordal
and I tell you that every cycle of
length greater than 3 has a cord so uh
so it must be that I haven't drawn all
the edges here yet right okay so
somebody tell let me number these guys
okay so somebody call out two numbers
and I'll join those number what 3 3 6 ok
from 3 or 6 there we go
ok but you're still not chordal somebody
on this side for one for one yawn that's
not helping much though
but it's okay you could add all the
edges it'll be coral for sure but I mean
in other words I I don't think that's
shortened any any of the cycles see I
had a cycle here one two three four five
six and and that was a cycle of length 6
so I have to have some cord in there
and I also have but you know I also had
this cycle length for here three - four
- five - six - three I got a I got to do
something there - okay so zero set zero
seven yeah I'm glad you didn't save zero
eight okay now are we done three five
here we go three one well okay now
everybody happy
well come on then Percy six okay
now we're seeing a now we must be there
right okay zero six okay now how about
that well one of the things I want to
tell you about is a nice pencil and
paper way to take take any given graph
and decide whether it's court'll but at
the moment I pretty happy with this one
and and so we'll use it later and check
it for sure okay so so that's a that's a
chordal graph now what's the smallest
graph that isn't chordal yeah yeah so
this this one is not chordal right
because it's got a cycle I'm going is
greater than 3 and no are no edges but
but if it has only three vertices you
cut it it's certainly you know the
definition by inviting fault that there
aren't any cycles of length greater than
three if you have only three vertices
okay so so that's that's a non coral
graph but now examples of a
or let's call this no and then you know
in the yes category then we have things
like this and well here's one right and
here's one that's chordal and here's
another one okay no problem there right
okay so we got lots of different anyway
and and there are many other families
graphs that are cooked it turns out that
for example an interval graph is always
coronal anybody knows what interval
graph it and so now in order to
understand this concept of chordal
graphs I think it turns out that the
most basic concept is the concept of
what they call a simplicial vertex ok so
a simplicial vertex V and this says that
all neighbors of V are neighbors of each
other of V are adjacent to each other ok
so it makes a simplex in other words
like like a tetrahedron art or something
like that so so you look at V and and
then you you check and see whether or
not all of its neighbors are are also
joined to each other so let's take let's
take this this graph and and which of
these vertices is simplicial upper left
is simplicial right because it has only
two neighbors and they're next to each
other okay now what about this guy
is this guy simplicial no because it's
got three neighbors and and it needs to
the opposite corners are not connected
there okay so this guy is not simplicial
what about him
okay and and again not lose their all
right
now on this one let me let me put star
on the simplicial vertices this guy here
no here yes here
no yeah cuz he's okay in this one no all
right how about this how about here what
okay I'll start I'll start here that
looks okay one e1 only one neighbor has
to be okay this guy same way this guy no
way got two neighbors that aren't doing
okay in here and here
you know I'm winning really big
simplicial okay so so that's one last
one I might as well do do this guy up
here I have any simplicial guys here at
zero no cuz one and eight are no good so
one has zero and two you know two one
three are joined that's fine but two is
also connected to six lol it's connected
to yeah so what do we say about two it's
got its got three neighbors and they're
all they're all in so we got a so two is
simplicial alright okay three has one
two three four five neighbors that it
must be no good what one and five
weren't joined okay for has three
neighbors and they're okay alright for
has three five and one and they're all
together
what happened oh one in five one in six
oh yeah okay I'm glad you're watching
and five is a loser six as a loser
because it has you know jumping across
here but eight looks eight looks okay
alright so we found two simplicial
vertices on this guy - all right now
there's a very nice theorem that we
start out with and that says that every
chordal graph has a simplicial vertex
and when I saw this theorem in a book I
you know it was given there without
approved and I this was just a survey
book it didn't didn't give any proofs it
just gave references and and so I sat
down I said okay this must be easy and
two hours later I was still trying to
find a direct proof in other words I
suppose I have a suppose I have a graph
that has no simplicial vertices in it
what can I conclude and I found that
every such graph after two hours I could
prove that every such graph had a path
of length five a path on 5 vertices and
and if I could if I could get arbitrary
large paths like I felt it was a good
shape but but then but I did realize
this this theorem isn't quite right
because you can consider the infinite
graph that has that's just a straight
line that goes off and you know in all
directions and and there's no simplicial
vertices there everybody has two
neighbors but they aren't connected so
what I I left a little space here so I
can write the word finite in there but
but that you know computer scientists
this is business just a no-brainer
everything every graph is finite how am
I going to pack it in the computer ok so
so
okay every finite chordal graph has a
simplicial vertex so so if I could if I
could prove from the assumption of knots
and policial verdicts that there was
that there were paths of arbitrary long
length then I would eventually get a
contradiction because I had exceed the
size of the graph but but anyway I don't
know about any any direct proof of this
result but there is a beautiful proof by
algorithm of this result so we can have
an algorithm that says it you know I
thought with a chordal graph and then I
I worked the algorithm and it turns out
that it can't the algorithm is going to
end and say here's a simplicial vertex
for you okay so so this algorithm is
something I found in Bob targets class
notes from spring of 1978 which I had
saved and never read and and I don't
know they how many people know this
Alvin but it's a beautiful beautiful one
the reason it probably hasn't gotten
famous is because if it's not obviously
yeah I guess it can't implement it in
linear time but you can implement it
pretty fast and almost always linear
time the average time has to be linear
so I'll show you that this nice
algorithm and and I will I'll illustrate
it on on the graph that you guys chose
for me here so I'll make another copy of
that ground zero one two three one two
three four five six yeah okay and when
we had here to here here to here comes
around now I'm not going to put the
numbers in no because I'm going to give
new numbers to these vertices and the
idea of the algorithm is is to put
numbers under on vertices let's see I've
got I'm missing somebody wonderful or
three two one
yeah I think now I think I've I've drawn
all those edges in yeah crossing over
one two three crossings yeah okay
so take another color here to put in
there now you can take any any vertex
that you want and and call it the vertex
number one so somebody tell me which
vertex I should start with still use
what has already labeled one that's a
good point
okay so let's let see that number okay
yeah
now now after you've got you know any
any number of vertices labeled and then
I can you know I got to put a two on
here and the rule is that I had that it
has to be I have to to be next to as
many as possible of the ones that
already have numbered so there's only
one guy numbered that means it has it
has to be next to one after I have to if
after I have five guys numbered then
they're not then there might there might
be some choices but but here I mean I
still got so so I you know has to be
next to one so it has to be either 2 3 4
6 or 0 so call out 6 okay so let's so
here's here's number 2 then all right
now for number 3 it's got to be such
it's got to be close to as many as
possible of these guys so if it's if
there's somebody next to both 1 & 2 then
then I've got to do it or if there's
several a guy - yeah you got a graph I
think it's not quite poorly yet what
there's a four cycle without a cord so
the four cycle without a court order to
discover that huh yeah that's equal call
it out one four five six one four five
six is the
cordless 4-cycle I you know I was
thinking of one three six zero but
that's no good okay so one four five six
is in the cordless force like okay now
what let's make it chordal okay still
okay but I'm not sure how this will
affect our simplicity which which edge
would you like to put in Percy zero five
one five is better yeah one five okay
all right so here we go got that guy in
there all right yeah okay I'm not sure
then who's simplicial anymore but let's
let's let that pass
what there's no to five edge doesn't so
one's not so official where's no to five
five five his next two six four three
and one and and so there's those six two
four right so five is no good and I
don't know the four hasn't become I
don't think forest becomes simplicial in
the meantime has it for is next two five
three six one is it for is okay now oh
okay - hasn't changed we haven't made
any more any anybody more adjacent to -
I see any of twos neighbors I don't
think we're okay but let's go with the
algorithm so now we number three where
am I going to put number three it has to
be something that's next to both one and
two and
and then so it could be here and it
could be this guy right what oh here
also yeah so my three choices okay Nick
the old three yeah yeah that's that's
Gospels heuristic okay so okay now how
about number four now is there anybody
that that's next to one two three and
four this guy here okay so now if
they're anybody's next to all of those
guys I don't think so
they have a whole bunch of neighbors but
but everybody's missing sighs how
they're so so now I mean you know our
choice before words between zero three
and five and and we've used both it took
two of those guys up and zero isn't
gonna work okay so now okay we can't get
all four but is there anybody that's
next to three of these okay well this
guy is good enough you think yes okay
it's connected to two what this guy's
connected to one two and three okay so
the total is there there's three guys
left now who this bit this guy certainly
hidden connected to anybody this guy's
next to one this guy next to two so I
got to do this guy next what oh this guy
this guy has I see this guy is it's
loaded with with neighbors okay okay so
so then this guy's seven and now I I
have but I guess got to go here eight
nine okay all right now okay you
understand the algorithm not it okay it
Bob called it max maximum cardinality
search
and and it is a pretty efficient way to
to implement this algorithm I namely we
we start out and we make a data
structure that has one entry for every
edge in the graph and and and then
initially we we put we put everything
saying of or we list the edges that have
that have K numbered neighbors so far so
initially no edge has any numbered
neighbors as soon as we number a
neighbor then all of its neighbors get
bumped up into another list and if we
keep these lists doubly linked and we
can do this book this just just bumping
up operation pretty fast so it's no big
deal to to choose always a an edge
that's in the in the list for largest K
so so anyway now we've got this and
there's the the or the numbering that we
that we have here has it has a very nice
property and here's the property which
Bob Tarjan called property P and and
it's I'm gonna I'm gonna try to sell
just stating it I'm gonna I'm gonna let
you discover it first to so let's
suppose I have three vertices you less
than V less than W in this numbering and
U is not next to V and U is X to W okay
so here's here I have three three
vertices that have been numbered so you
know this might be two of five and six
or something like this I'm not sure what
the where it appears in this diagram but
anyway let's assume that we that we have
done this algorithm and and and we have
three vertices that we've numbered at
some point
where
we have v-cut numbered after you but it
was not next to you w got numbered after
V but it was next to you okay now
maybe we have a contradiction or what
can we do okay so now what can we say
what we can say is that at the moment
when 20 when V was numbered was numbered
it had a certain number of numbered
neighbors let's say T numbered neighbors
and when when when W was numbered so
when W was numbered it had less than or
equal to T numbered neighbors okay this
is this is like this is our rule because
we had a choice when we were numbering V
we could have chosen W and if W had more
neighbors then I'm sorry when when when
V was numbered W had less than or equal
to number of neighbors yeah that's good
keep me on my toes here so therefore but
but but the V I had T number neighbors
but they weren't you alright so but W
has has you as one of its its neighbors
and so I I conclude that there is a
number that there's a vertex X okay so
conclude there exists a and X that is
less than V and X is is next to V it is
adjacent to V and X is not adjacent to W
with me because X had you know we had
these teeth neighbors and it anything
you know like like say five so he has
five neighbors and they don't include
you know so but but the W has has up to
five neighbors and it does include you
and so there's got to be some new guy X
who was already numbered that V knows
but W didn't know okay that's that's
that's the conclusion
so that's property P if if we can find
three vertices like this you not next to
V but you is next to W then we can then
there must be some other some vertex X X
well it can't be it can't be you
so it has to be some new guy that I
haven't haven't seen before and it is
next to be but not next to W okay so
this is this is property P now that's a
property of this algorithm and now I'm
gonna do I'm gonna tell you what a bad
induced path is and then we're almost
done with this technical part here so so
what's a bad induced path now first of
all when I when I talk about an induced
graph I should really get back to basic
graph theory
so go off I have I have G is a graph and
then I and I say G
restricted to u so U is some subset of
the vertices this is G restricted to the
vertices of you so let's say the whole
set of vertices is capital V and then U
is some subset of capital V so this
notation is something like you know in
probability theory you can say something
given
thing else we restrict G to a small
subset of adversity if G is chordal then
and and it is that then G reflected to
you is also corridor in fact G is
chordal is if and only if G has no G 3G
respected to you is not equal to a cycle
of length greater than 3 if I look at
all the induced subgraphs of G I never
have a cycle that has no cord this is
this is another way to state the
definition it's for all all you
contained in the set of vertices ok so a
chordal graph is a graph that doesn't
contain all these induced subgraph these
are the minimal non-core graphs ok so so
now what my talk about a bad induced
path that's a path that's induced by
vertices that look like this so here I
have a path so I have a path is a bunch
of vertices that each each is next to
the net is adjacent to the next guy and
and let's call this V 0 V 1 V 2 V 3 V 4
V k k is the guy at the end of the path
and I'm going to assume that K is
greater than 1 not that it equals 5 but
there's at least there's at least 3
vertices here and and the and the
condition is that V 0 is less than V K
and that's less than all the other guys
so in the numbering now when I say it's
an induced path that means that I've
shown all of the adjacencies here these
0 is not a neighbor of V 2 or 3 P 3 or
anything else
v 1 has only two neighbors
among these these guys shown I mean
might have other neighbors that but but
if I if I if I if I just consider these
six vertices then there are no other
edges between those six vertices there
might be edges out to the out to the
outside but they're okay and I but in my
numbering I said I chose this guy first
and then I chose this guy and then I
chose all the others later and I'm going
to prove that that that can't happen
okay property P implies that there's
nobody
okay so property P implies there is no
bad induced path all right now this is
this is the kind of interesting argument
because it's not the normal usually when
you try to prove something like this you
you prove it by the induction on K on
the length of the path but I'm going to
prove it by induction on on V 0 plus V K
the sum of the numbers at the beginning
in the end so now you guys in the front
row who have been catching all my other
errors watch this closely because this
is good but well people in the back can
can watch it closely too if you want but
the guys in these guys are really are
really eagle-eye here in the front okay
so so okay so I'm going to show that the
let's suppose I have a bad induced path
and I choose a bad induced path which
the sum of of these two numbers at the
at the endpoints is as small as possible
okay so now
I've got a interesting situation here
that property P says that there exists
an X with X is less than VK and X is
adjacent to VK and X is not adjacent to
V 1 V 1 is it so I'm applying property P
which you can see there at the top of
your screen right with V 0 V K and V 1
in his position here so wait a minute
yeah V 0 is not adjacent to VK there's
no edge from V 0 to V K and and there is
an edge however from v-0 to v1 all right
so therefore there exists an X that's
less than VK that's my view here and
it's adjacent to the UK and not adjacent
to v1 all right
there we are ok so so there's some other
vertex X no that's not not in the
picture here you know so we got X
sitting out here somewhere and it's next
to V I'm sorry X is X is sitting here
less than VK it's next to be K and well
X might be might be adjacent to some
other guys it might be you know but
think of K is 5 here but so X is next to
V 5 it might be next to be for it but
it's not next to V 1 like you know
definitely not no not to be next and be
1 so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take the the the smallest J so the
smallest J with X not next to
Vijay I'm sorry X is next to Vijay so so
X is X is next to v5 here but and but
not v1 so there's going to be a smallest
case where where it is and so J is
greater than 1 because X is not adjacent
to v1 and so now let me take a look then
at at at at some pass here I go
v-0 v1 up to V J and then X this is a oh
okay thanks Jason
all right now there's like there's
another there's another possibility here
x VJ V 1 V 0 anyway I know that I have
all these adjacencies here and I don't
have any and these are induced pairs
because there aren't any other edges
here X is yeah I know I don't have any
edges between the V's and X is not next
to any of these other other V's either
because I took J to be the smallest and
and I flipped in both ways because one
of those two will have to be a bad
induced path depending on whose smaller
X or V 0 okay because X X is less than
all the V 1 3 K because it was less than
okay so it's possible that you know
Jamie might be equal to kid but anyway
one of these two is is
bad induce death but the some of the of
the two end points is is smaller you
know X plus V naught is less than X plus
y less than VK plus V naught which which
was I assume that I had there the
smallest so that's my proof okay so is
this can't go on and I
you can't keep getting smaller and
smaller bad induce pass and that's the
reason why there's no bad induce path
okay so end of the end of cook above
proof that property P shows there's no
bad induced path and now we get not how
we get the easy stuff we can read off
all kind of corollaries and one core
layer is that that the corollary 1/n is
a simplicial vertex and that by n I mean
the vertex that cut numbered last so
here's our here's our diagram that n is
nine nine is a simplicial vertex hey
right okay
must be true right now but what but why
why can I claim that that that you know
because suppose I have two neighbors and
probably have two neighbors of n you
know I have these it is next to N and W
is next in I have to prove that V is a
neighbor of W okay so if if V is it is
it is not next to W then they're both
less than n then V and W is a bad
it is the bad induced path because this
would be a path with V not next to W ok
so the bad
Douce path and there aren't any bad
induce path so that's it so in other
words uh you know the the last vertex to
be numbered in this algorithm always has
to be simplicial all of its neighbors
have to be next to each other otherwise
we'd have a really short bad induce path
okay um
next at every step
kay is a simplicial is a simplicial with
respect to G given the previous vertices
the previous numbered vertices whenever
I whenever I'm number in the graph at
every step uh I've got a chordal graph
and I've and so and I've induced a
smaller graph which has to be court'll
to every every every induced graph of a
chordal graph is chordal and so all the
way through everything was was that you
know k is the last vertex of this after
I've numbered K I'm sorry this is K is
simplicial with respect to the first K
numbered vertices the last last vertex
that I've numbered is always a
simplicial in any chordal graph and and
G restricted to the first K vertices is
chordal so so well that's great because
look at it says all the neighbors of K
that were previously numbered we're in
fact formed a clique they are next to
each other and then I add K to this and
now I got an even bigger click you know
you know the word click this is a
important thing about a clique in the
graph everybody every everybody knows
each other everybody is a neighbor
everybody everybody else in the clique
yeah in in the clique so so a it's an
induced complete graph and either click
so the idea that is that that we we know
that during this process every time I
every time I numbered something it
turned out that that all of the
previously numbered neighbors of the guy
formed a clique it wasn't just a you
know I when we did the numbering we were
just trying to maximize the number of
the that how many numbered guys there
were that that that we were Jason to but
it turns out that when we're doing that
if we keep if we're doing that it also
has to be a clique and and well look at
this situation then suppose I have it
for they have have some arbitrary graph
whatsoever and and let's say it's
chordal and then I have a new vertex V
and I find some click here inside of G
everything is connected and then I
connect all of those guys to V alright I
claim that this graph is is always
chordal if g if g was quartel that then
i can extend it to a larger chordal
graph by taking any new vertex and any
clique in g and and connect v to that
clique it doesn't have to be the largest
possible clique it can be a single point
but but it can be zero points but anyway
i
I can I can build up any I can start out
with empty graph and I can step-by-step
and had one vertex at a time always find
some click 'add what I have before add a
new vertex and I claim it's chordal well
why is that true
as we can see what all the all these
cycles are in this graph suppose suppose
this graph had a you know had a five
cycle in it somewhere
well that five cycle can't lie inside of
G because G is yeah I mean induced five
cycle it can't lie inside of G because
you know if you use chordal so it has to
so V has to be somewhere here but then V
is adjacent to this guy and this guy so
these guys have to be next to each other
so so so so this is a way to build lots
and lots of chordal graphs and what I
just showed by the algorithm is that in
fact you get all chordal graphs that way
because you start out with any chordal
graph and you do your numbering
algorithm and it builds the graph just
by this method every new numbered L
vertex is is connected to some to some
clique in the previous graph okay
I think this is so you know it's worth
looking over again so you know this this
this lecture is going on the internet
and you can I'm told that people like
like to watch lectures that are only ten
minutes long at most and so you know did
you know they're gonna record the whole
darn thing but you can just divide it up
into ten minute segments okay so okay so
anyway I think it's a real cool
algorithm and and it gives you all cord
aggressive and and then we're gonna so
and it turns out that and that that this
gives a structure to not only does it
give us the chordal graphs but it gives
us a structure which is going to help us
solve lots of other problems on chordal
graphs I mean the reason that coils have
so important application is because they
have some kind of structure and and this
algorithm does it okay now so anyway let
me show you then what what I did back in
July I was playing around with it and I
said okay
another name for chordal graphs is the
triangulated graph so I started out with
with a with my favorite
triangulated graphic yeah I like
triangular grids and so I mean that this
arises and lots of puzzles and also if
people like bowling so we have a
triangle it needed graph here and I
wanted to to find a numbering for it
alright so um I started out and well
okay you can help me you can help me
number this which vertex should i do
first look take somebody from over here
bottom guy okay
oh look one sorry that was like we start
with one on this numbering scheme here
has to be a neighbor go to the left or
the right call it out left I want to
prove that I'm having planned this in
advance you see okay okay now it has to
be a common neighbor of one and two so I
think I'm forced here now yep now right
now I got a gate as close as I can to
two of these I can't get hit all of them
so it looks like I got a do this guy has
got to be number four and then what
now I know I have two choices I can go
left or right again okay now I I wanna I
can hit two and four I can hit four and
five left to right okay that's this dis
guy right okay so now I got three
choices left middle right seven okay now
i i i yeah i i'm never gonna be able to
hit three at a time because there's only
triangles here right
what are the six what do you want to do
left them six eight okay
now you might notice something here
I just number eight and it was next is
four and six but its neighbors do not
for more click I mean eight it's not is
also next to seven and understand so
eight is next to three guys and they
aren't next to each other right so what
do I conclude this graph was not curdled
well where's the where's the why isn't
it coral where's that cycle where's the
where's the induced cycle but I missed
yeah it's just got here eight six five
three two seven induce cycle there's no
nothing joining that hexagon okay too
bad okay so wasn't coral it was but I
thought it was triangulated this work
that's why people don't call it triangle
a two graphs I think no because
confusing you can look at it something
like this and think this is triangulated
isn't it no but it isn't okay so so
let's scratch that not a chordal graph
and in fact my other than for for
finding the möbius function didn't work
on it's on his graph too bad for that
too now okay but let's make it coral by
adding adding some chords okay so we had
this this this this hexagon what well
we're gonna have to like I'm gonna put
that one in but that's still not that
still has a has a five cycle so so
anyway I'm gonna I'm gonna make it
symmetrical for fun and and and and now
I've got to graph that that it got it
looks looks more chordal alright okay
now now here's the climax of my talk
coming up now it better be because I
well I started a little late but it's
it's
approaching 5:30 here namely the the the
clicks of a chordal graph can be
arranged into a into it a forest
actually if if the graph is connected
it's a tree so we have what's called the
click tree of a chordal graph and if
it's what clique it's really a clique
forest because if the graph isn't
connected that then the trees aren't
connected to each other we got a bunch
of but anyway though the tick tick
quarry is a clique tree it is all
arranging all all maximal cliques of G
into a tree structure and not and I want
to explain that because this is where
chordal graphs come up come and entries
come together we're going to we're going
to represent every chordal graph by a
tree and so I have to explain this now
first of all a maximal clique a maximal
clique is a clique that you can't add
any anybody new to there's always if I
try to add it add any new guys it's not
going to be a clique anymore so that's
what a maximal clique is in in in this
graph let's take a look at the maximal
cliques in fact during the construction
I had a picture that I yeah go back to
this picture here
I started out remember with a coil graph
and I add a new vertex echoes some click
in there and either the new vertex and I
and I can I examine any possible induced
cycle in this graph now we can also in
this graph we can also say
what is it what what do its maximal
cliques look like okay so the maximal
cliques in this new graph that we built
up by adding a new vertex to a to a
previous go well they're either they're
either contained entirely in G or they
they involve the involve V but now
there's only one maximal clique
involving V because because you know you
know V is put this thing is is a clique
and and we can editing anybody new to it
without making it not a clique so so so
all the maximal cliques here either were
Mac were maximal in G or or they're this
one new guy and it's possible that that
that that this one that that I that I
chosen G was was maximal in G in which
case it's no longer maximal it's right
but the conclusion is that if you have a
chordal graph you don't have very many
maximal cliques in general a graph can
have a huge number exponentially many
maximal cliques but you know lots of
triangles for example this this guy here
every every triangle it is a maximal
clique okay but well like I don't have
to give you a better example in order to
get exponentially many but anyway you
can have lots and lots of maximal
cliques and so but in a coral graph you
only have at most n if they're inverses
in fact n minus one so so the so what
happens is then we a whole bunch of
clicks c1 c2 c3 up to CN by the
algorithm
the numbering algorithm c1 is just the
vertex one by itself
c2 is 2 and the guy that that it was
written that we were joined to c3 is the
is the clique the maximal clique of
among one two three and and so on at
every stage I have a chordal graph and
and and I take the CSV is equal to V and
the click and and the previous clique of
of numbered vertices that were less than
V so I and I'm going to show you how we
can make this into a clique tree now
that's that's a beautiful pattern so so
go through the algorithm one more time
on this graph with n vertices let's do
the numbering algorithm and and fast
tell me where to start so I start at the
bottom again okay so they're not we were
already been there and done that now you
said what 2 and 3 we have to we have to
number the guy 4 and at the next point
you said go to the right we had to break
symmetry what that's no good now I'm
forced to do what 2 & 3 & 4 5 is it
connected or this guy is connected to
them all right so I could put 6 here no
what happened to go sees
5 has to go here yes okay thank you
because yeah I'm sorry it wasn't
adjacent there yeah I'm sorry so Phi
this guy is a it is next to all three in
this triangle yeah you're right okay now
I've got I've got a big click here size
for let me write down the the cliques
here see one is is 1 c2 is
1 2 C 3 is 1 2 3 C 4 or less equal to 2
3 2 3 4 C 5 was 5 2 3 4 5 C 6 coming up
where do you want 6 up here looks pretty
good 3 4 5 6
yeah this is ok c7 wait quit 6 is not
next to two it looks like it might be in
my diagram but I didn't see 7 so so I
think I can do another one here
something next is 3 5 & 6 3 4 what 3 4 &
this guy is now next 2 3 4 & 6 right ok
this is 7 so this is a 3 4 6 7 ok c8
what up here 8 yeah
ok so that's now 8 is next 2 5 6 & 4
okay and so now like 9 and 10 are sort
of left over here so we got 5 8 9 and
and see 10 is 6 7 10 okay now let me
show you the click tree that that we get
in this way so um I start out and I have
I have
well I got 1 2 3
I have 1 1 and then 1 2 but they get
wiped out so left with 1 2 3 and then 2
3 4
I put it next to one two three then two
three four five I put it neck oh it
absorbed the one two three so so um I
got two three two three four five
absorbs two three four is no longer
maximal click OK now three four five six
I I can do then three four five see yeah
three four six seven I can put it here
four or five six eight at this point I
have to find some vertex that contains
four or five and six and so I put here
four five six eight five eight nine I
have to find a vertex that contains five
and eight and that's this one and six
seven ten I have to find a vertex I
contain six and seven and this and adds
this one well at every step I add a new
vertex V you know C sub K is always has
Kate that's the last guy and then the
other vertices they have to appear
together and and that's going to be a
property that you can verify it's always
going to be true and sometimes you have
a choice but in this particular case you
did so so I won't up here with one two
three four five six seven maximal
cliques in this graph and that's all the
maximal cliques there are because
because they systematically as we
generated them we we were getting all
possible new maximal cliques and the the
fact that there's always somebody that
you can join to next is not hard to
prove it's not it's an observation made
by a guy named Peter Peter Berner moon
in 1978 paper and he was studying he was
studying phylogenetic trees he you know
that
people in biology try to figure out the
evolutionary history and and what what
leads to somebody's genes that they have
now based on not the different mutation
and and so he was working on on that
problem and he came across the concept
of chordal graphs and and he came up
with this idea which which was which is
equivalent to what we now know as the
idea of click trees and it it turns out
then that there always is a a click tree
for a chordal graph and this is going to
in fact define the coil graph so what
I've done is the the clicked tree that
has vertices which are the maximal
cliques of of G and and they have the
interesting property that is if you look
at all of the maximal cliques that
contain any particular vertex there
always they always form a subtree of
this clique tree so in other words the
work that one only appears here to
appears here in here these two or
subtree three appears one two three
these four guys have contain three so
that's that's a subtree of the street
four or five four appears in this
subtree here who had the branch point in
it five appears in one two three in
these four guys six appears in these
four guys seven appears needs two guys
eight appears here nine appears only
here ten appears only there and and and
up I claim that this clique tree defines
this original graph namely two vertices
are adjacent in the original graph if
and only if their sub trees intersect
you see every at every vertex I showed
it was a it was a sub tree of this
trees so I'll redraw the tree it has
seven nodes to it right it has a center
node and and and one two three four five
okay and and so that this is this is
node what this is one this subtree is to
this subtree here is three then four is
it goes like here here here it the
subtree for for this my diagram isn't
too beautiful here
this is the one four four two one four
five i let's say is here the one four
sixes is here and the one four seven is
it's here and one four eight is here and
then then there's a nine of ten what
I've done is I've I marked down ten
subtrees of this tree and and and where
where those sub trees overlap so you
know this was number one this was number
nine this was number ten and so on this
is number eight so so I've got you can
see the sub trees but been looking where
where the threes appear that's the sub
tree for three but but you can also
think of them as you know as things that
might intersect and so if I want to know
you know that is three adjacent to five
well then I just look at the sub tree
for three in the sub tree for five and
and and I see if those two intersect so
so this is a generalized I started with
any tree and and and you can you define
sub trees connect the sub trees on that
tree and and it turns out you always get
a chordal graph this way by this
intersection property so every every
every
tree every set of sub trees of a tree
that that are obtainable you know you
can write the vertices you you can take
any any tree you want and start writing
vertex numbers in them as long as you
always make make every where you put a
three has to be connected to all the
other threes within the overall tree
that will define a chordal graph it's
it's right really easy to see that that
well almost really easy to see that that
that that construction always gives you
a quarrel graph and conversely every
chordal graph has has a structure like
this has a clique tree you can write
them you write the vertices as a maximal
cliques and and so I can represent the
whole tree by by knowing that the
maximal clique and and that's why a lot
of algorithms on chordal graphs are
efficient because they they walk through
the clique tree and and you convert the
other problem on graphs to a problem on
the clique tree any questions I don't
know I I bet there is but I don't think
like but I don't know of any great great
generating functions or anything like
that yeah I I'm gonna write about
chordal graphs in section seven point
four point two of the art of computer
programming I'm writing section seven
point two point two right now and and I
just sort of dived into my my collection
of of notes than seven four two because
I came because I was working on on this
other algorithm in July so I'm a little
ahead of myself so but but certainly the
first thing to do would be to enumerate
all the chordal graphs of small order
and then look it up in the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences and
see if anybody has has done that
another question interesting
applications I would say yeah no I mean
their applications galore but but but I
mean these people who discovered it all
discovered it because they were working
on application and and they came from
from different different groups I mean
certainly got it in linear algebra if
you have a chordal graph if if the
pattern of coefficients in your matrix
is is coital then it gives you a what's
called a perfect elimination ordering so
for solving linear equations and and the
the you know the other name was rigid
circuit graphs well you know this this
this graph that I thought was
triangulated it now to read the circuit
graph it's not rigid enough Wiggles too
much but added these these three extra
spokes in there and all of a sudden its
rigid yeah but but I there there's you
know the fast ways to color chordal
graphs there's fast ways to certify
independent sets and chordal graphs and
almost every problem you know that's
that that's np-hard on general graphs
that has a some kind of efficient
algorithm I'm chordal graphs at and on
trees usually not not always but so yeah
the definition of kurtal graphs is
around the number three is there
something around four oh well those are
those are our graphs that are definable
by by excluded minors but but I so yeah
there's lots and lots of generalizations
to so-called perfect graphs and things
like this
so chordal graphs are the ones that that
that have the most application so the
others are more you know just for people
who
who want to generalize things more so I
hope you I can't think of a good joke on
the last chord now so I'll have to end
you